the sad part of it is that the Democrat
the truth is they want more censorship
they want more censorship by online
platforms of disfavored views of what
they consider hate speech of the
so-called deplorables
I mean and this is I I genuinely it is
genuinely sad because I was raised
Democrat I was very Progressive uh
radical left as a young man you know
when I graduated from high school the
Supreme Court
had a ruling that you could burn the
American flag Republicans were aghast
this the Democrats felt like it was a
victory for free speech ACLU defend the
right of neo-nazis to March through a
neighborhood of Holocaust survivors in
skogy Illinois
so the Democrats and liberals were the
party of free speech for most of my life
and that really starts to change with
the rise of cancel culture and wokism
in the in the really the late in the
2010s or so